It's good to be among scholars,
not among
barely literate YouTube rabble
[laughter]
when they're unrefined, unsophisticated
videos.
Lots of people think that the satanic
verses is just the title of a Salman
Rushy novel, but the story of the
Satanic Verses goes all the way back to
7th century Arabia. Rashi's novel is
called the Satanic Verses because it
contains a fictionalized dream sequence
about one of the most embarrassing
events in the life of Muhammad.
According to our earliest Muslim
sources, Muhammad, the prophet of Islam,
once delivered a revelation from Satan.
This revelation promoted belief in three
pagan goddesses, Allat, Aloo, and Manat,
as intercessors with Allah.
If these stories are correct, Muhammad
was tricked into committing the worst
possible sin in Islam, the sin of sherk
or associating partners with Allah.
Following the western tradition will
refer to what's reported in these
sources as the satanic versus incident.
Islamic tradition refers to this as the
story of the cranes. Cranes as in birds.
And we'll soon see why.
During the first two centuries of Islam,
there was a virtual consensus
that some version of the satanic versus
incident occurred. There was a near
consensus that it happened.
Today in Islam, there's a virtual
consensus that no version of the satanic
versus incident occurred. There's a near
consensus that it didn't happen.
This is especially interesting because
there are so many different Muslim
groups in the world with different
methodologies.
Many of these groups priding themselves
on getting their beliefs
about Islam from the early Muslim
community. And yet on this topic, they
believe the opposite of what the early
Muslim community believed. and they
frequently regard anyone who agrees with
the early Muslim community as heretical.
So we have a mystery on our hands. How
do you go from a near consensus that
something happened to a near consensus
that it didn't happen? Turns out we know
exactly why the Muslim community changed
its collective mind about the satanic
verses. Islamic theology changed and
this theological change compelled Muslim
scholars to rewrite history for the sake
of the evolving orthodoxy.
To understand how a theological change
led to a historical change, we'll begin
by reading one version of the satanic
versus incident to familiarize ourselves
with the story. Then we'll consider how
non-Muslims evaluate the historicity of
the story. And we'll contrast this with
how Muslims evaluate the historicity of
the story. And finally, we'll see how
the Islamic theologically induced
revision of history should cause
thoughtful Muslims to re-evaluate the
real source of their beliefs.
Here's one of the mediumlength reports
of the Satanic versus incident. This is
quoted by Tabi in both his history and
his Quran commentary.
The messenger of God, Muhammad, was
seated in a large gathering of Kuresh,
that's Muhammad's tribe. He desired that
day that nothing come to him from God
that would cause them to turn away from
him. Muhammad didn't want to receive a
revelation that would lead to further
hostility from his tribe.
And God sent down by the star when it
sets. Your companion has not gone
astray, nor is he misguided. Those are
the opening two verses of Surah 53. And
the messenger of God recited it until he
reached. Have you seen Allat al- Usa and
Manat III, the other three pagan
goddesses that were especially dear to
Muhammad's tribe? When Satan cast two
phrases upon him, those high garnic
garnic is untransated here. It's usually
translated as cranes, which makes most
sense because the idea is that they're
like birds that can carry your prayers
up to Allah.
Indeed, their intercession is hoped for.
He uttered the two phrases. Then he went
on and recited the whole surah.
At the end of the surah, he made the
sagda, prostration, and the whole
gathering made the sagda with him. Wed
bin al-mulira took some of the dirt to
his forehead and made the sagda upon it.
He was an old man and was unable to make
the sagda fully. He had trouble
prostrating because of his age.
They were satisfied with what he had
uttered and said, "We know that Allah
gives life and death and that it is he
who creates and sustains, but these gods
of ours intercede with him on our behalf
and when you give them a share, we are
with you." So Muhammad's tribe believed
that Allah is supreme. But they also
believed that Allah, al-Usa and Manat
intercede with Allah on their behalf.
Muhammad finally agreed with them. So
they decided to support Muhammad.
In the evening, Jabriel, supposedly the
angel Gabriel, came to him and he, the
prophet, went over the sura with him.
When he the prophet reached the two
phrases Satan had cast upon him, he
Jabriel said, "I did not bring you
these." And the messenger of God said,
"I have fabricated against God and have
said on God's behalf that which he did
not say." So God revealed to him and
they strove to tempt you away from that
with which we have inspired you that you
might fabricate against us something
other than it until his words and then
you would have found no helper against
us or 17 73 to 75.
He remained distressed and anxious until
there came down
and we have not sent before you a
messenger or a prophet to his words and
God is all knowing all wise. So Muhammad
was still worried about what he had done
until Allah revealed this verse surah
22:52
which we'll look at in a moment.
The immigrants in Abbiscinia heard that
all the people of Mecca had accepted
Islam. So they returned to their clans
saying they are dearer to us. And they
found the people had reverted to their
former condition when God had abregated
what Satan cast. Some of the Muslim
community had moved to Abbiscinia,
modern Ethiopia, to avoid persecution.
But they decided to return to Mecca when
they heard that the polytheists had
embraced Islam. By the time they
returned, however, the polytheists were
enemies yet again because Muhammad took
back what he had said.
Let's look at the two most relevant
Quran passages according to the story of
the satanic verses. Surah 53:es 19 to 22
depending on the translation originally
said something like this. Have you not
heard of Allat and Alsa and Manat III
the other? These are the exalted cranes
whose intercession is to be hoped for.
This promoted the intercession of pagan
goddesses
in the Quran. Now the passage says,
"Have you not heard of Allat and Alsa
and Manat the third the other? Are yours
the males and his the females?" That
indeed is an unfair division.
Instead of promoting the intercession of
pagan goddesses, it's asking why the
Arabs would ascribe three daughters to
Allah when the Arabs prefer male
offspring. Why are you saying Allah has
daughters and you guys don't like
daughters?
The other most relevant passage is surah
22:52 which Allah revealed to comfort
Muhammad after he realized what he had
done. Allah declares, "And we did not
send before you any apostle or prophet,
but when he desired, Satan made a
suggestion respecting his desire, but
Allah annulls that which Satan casts."
Then does Allah establish his
communications, and Allah is knowing
wise. In other words, Muhammad, don't
worry about this too much because it
happens to all prophets from time to
time.
and that comforted Muhammad.
There are two primary ways we can
investigate the authenticity of the
satanic versus incident. First, we can
apply the method that historians use to
investigate events, the historical
method. Second, we can apply the method
that Muslims use when they investigate
Islamic history. It's not criticism.
We'll consider both methods and see
where the evidence points.
How would a non-Muslim historian
approach the satanic verses? We'll keep
this simple. The first question a
historian is going to ask is, "What do
our earliest sources say?" Generally,
earlier reports are more reliable than
later reports because later reports are
more likely to be embellished or
influenced by people's biases.
So, early testimony is extremely
important and we have to ask what the
early Muslim historians said. Here we
find that our earliest biographical
records such as Iban Associ
contain satanic versus reports. We also
know that even earlier sources contained
reports of the satanic verses. This
isn't something that was invented late
in Islamic history. This is something
that goes back to the first century of
Islam.
The next question a historian is going
to ask is how many sources are there? Is
the story found in just one source or do
we find it in multiple historical
reports? The idea here is that if we
only have one source telling us that an
event occurred, it's possible that
someone made it up. But if we have
multiple reports telling us the same
thing, seems less likely that someone
simply invented it. So when we
investigate the satanic verses,
how many historical reports are we
dealing with?
>> One or two?
five, 10.
We have at least 50 Muslim sources
reporting this incident. Not one, not
two, 50.
And if you'd like to read all 50, the
late Harvard scholar, Shahab Ahmed,
unquestionably the greatest authority on
the Satanic Versus incident in history,
translated all 50 of them in his book,
Before Orthodoxy: The Satanic Verses in
Early Islam. We already read his
translation of one of them. So, not only
do we find the satanic verses in our
earliest biographical sources, we also
find that we have an absolutely
astounding number of reports.
At this point, the historian is going to
ask whether these sources are
independent. That is, are a bunch of
sources just copying from one source? If
that's the case, then even if you have a
bunch of sources, there's really only
one source, the original source that
everyone else copied. So, how many
independent sources do we have here? The
isnads, the chains of transmission, come
in handy because Muslims often kept
records of where they got their stories.
Of the 50 sources we have for this
story, seven go back to Kab al-Qazi,
one of Islam's greatest early Quran
scholars, six go back to Erwa Iban al-
Zuber, an early Meccan scholar who is
known as the founder of the study of the
life of Muhammad. He was also Aisha's
nephew, Abu Bakr's grandson, and the son
of Abu Bakr's daughter, Asma, one of the
first 20 converts to Islam.
Five go back to Abu Aliyah al-Basri,
another of the greatest Quranic scholars
of the first century. He studied the
Quran with Kaleiff Umar, Uba Ibn Kab,
Zade Ibn Tabat and Iban Abbas.
Two go back to Alsudi, another early
scholar who studied with Ibn Abbas.
Three reports go back to Kata Iban, one
of Islam's greatest early commentators.
Two go back to Abu Bakr Ib Abdul Rahman,
Ibn Al-Hared, one of the top scholars in
Islamic law during the first century of
Islam.
One comes from the tapsier of Muhammad
Ib al-Sib al- Kali, an early commentator
who composed the longest tapsier that
had been written up until his time.
One goes back to Al Dahak Ibn Muzahim
al-Balki, a first century expert in
tapsier.
Four go back to Maktal Ibn Sullean, a
Quran scholar who wrote the earliest
surviving complete tapsier of the Quran.
Three go back to Mujahed Iban Jabar who
was a student of Iban Abbas and was
called during his lifetime the most
learned man alive in Tapsir.
One goes back to Ikramma, a slave of Ibn
Abbas and an expert on the life of
Muhammad.
We have 10 reports that go back to
Muhammad's cousin, Ibn Abbas, the
founder of Quranic studies. When I talk
about different reports, all being
traced back to the same scholar, here's
a graphic of what I mean. These are the
reports that are traced back just to
Muhammad's cousin, Ibn Abbas, by all
these different chains of transmission.
Ibn Abbas is at the top. All these other
people are transmitting what came from
him.
We have three that go back to Sed Ibn
Juber, one of the leading Quranic
scholars of his time and one of the top
students of Ibn Abbas. Some of Ibn
Abbas's narratives go through Sahed Iban
Juber.
And we have two that go back to
Al-Hassan al-Basri, an early scholar of
the Quran and of Sharia.
Some of these aren't completely
independent because several of these
guys knew each other and studied under
each other, but there are a lot of
independent sources here. It's clear
then that we have numerous independent
sources for the satanic verses.
These are some of the main criteria a
historian would use in evaluating the
satanic verses. We have early sources
going back to the first century of Islam
if you trace them back. We have multiple
sources somewhere in the neighborhood of
50 and we have independent sources
including a number of Islam's best first
century historians and commentators.
But we can go even further. Historians
also apply principles such as the
principle of embarrassment. The
principle of embarrassment states that
as a general rule, dedicated followers
of a religious leader don't invent
embarrassing stories about their leader.
If they're going to invent a story, it's
going to be something positive. Stories
about the leader performing miracles,
for instance. What this means is that it
just doesn't seem very likely that a
bunch of Muslims decided one day to
invent a story about Muhammad delivering
revelations from the devil.
And if non-Muslims had invented it,
Muslim scholars certainly wouldn't have
passed it on as if it really happened.
So, it seems absurd to claim that this
story was a fabrication. By far the most
plausible explanation for the data we
have is that at least some historical
core behind these accounts is true.
We can see then why most non-Muslim
scholars regard this event as
indisputable. The great Oxford scholar
Guom, for instance, says this. It is
impossible to suggest a motive that
would induce the early Muslims to write
such a story about the prophet unless it
were true. If historical evidence is to
be given any value, we must hold that
Muhammad pronounced these words in the
middle of Surah 53.
And Montgomery Watt concludes, Muhammad
must have publicly recited the satanic
verses as part of the Quran. It is
unthinkable that the story could have
been invented by Muslims or forced upon
them by non-Muslims.
[clears throat]
Now, at this point, Muslims usually make
it clear that they don't care much about
non-Muslim historical methods. They say,
"Our scholars have looked at the chains
of transmission for these stories, and
they don't meet our rigorous standards
for historicity."
If you're not familiar with the Muslim
method of historical investigation,
Muslims have stories about Muhammad, and
those stories come with lists of names.
I got it from so- and so. Who got it
from so- and so? Who got it from so and
so? and so on. A Muslim scholar then
looks at these names and if he's
convinced that everyone on the list is
trustworthy and he doesn't have any
major objections to the story, he
concludes that the story is true. If the
Muslim scholar doesn't like all the
names on the list, he rejects the story.
This is the standard Muslim excuse for
rejecting all kinds of historical
information about Muhammad, but it's
based on a complete misunderstanding of
the proper application of Isnad
criticism.
In the early centuries of Islam, there
were three main genres of Islamic
literature.
First, there was the Sira magazi
literature which consisted of
straightforward historical narratives
about Muhammad or the battles of the
early Muslim community. The emphasis of
the Sira magazi scholars wasn't on
establishing doctrine or practice. The
emphasis was on providing a biography of
Muhammad and sometimes of his
companions.
Second, there was the tapsir literature.
Tapsir scholars provided commentary on
the Quran. They weren't obsessed with
having chains of transmission going back
to a companion of Muhammad, although
they would sometimes include Isnad
chains. But the Tapsier scholars would
often include any important
interpretations of the Quran that they
could find. That's why if you look up a
Quran verse in Tapsier Kabi or Tapsier
ibn Cir, they might give you a dozen or
more interpretations of what a Quran
verse means.
Third, there was the Hadith literature.
The hadith literature consisted of
sayings and deeds that established
orthodox Islamic doctrine and practice.
And this was so important to them that
they came up with a methodology that
supposedly guaranteed the accuracy of
their reports.
Here's the key. These three kinds of
literatures had different methodologies.
The hadith scholars insisted on having
complete isnads that go all the way back
to a companion of Muhammad. The Sira
magazi scholars often gave abbreviated
isnads or they would simply appeal to a
known authority on some issue. They had
a different methodology
and the tapsier scholars would try to
incorporate everything they could find
from respected commentators about
whatever Quran verses they were
commenting on.
Now, here's where the error comes in.
The main reports of the satanic verses
are found in the Siraagazi literature
and in the tapsir literature.
We read about the satanic verses in
biographies
and in Quran commentaries.
Think about why.
What orthodox Islamic belief or practice
is established by the satanic versus
incident?
none. It's biographical information
about Muhammad and it's the background
of certain verses in the Quran. That's
why the reports are found in the simazi
literature and in the taps literature.
This means that the reports should be
judged based on the standards and
methodology
of the Sira magazi scholars and the taps
scholars, not on the standards and
methodology
of the Hadith scholars who had a
different purpose and a different
methodology.
But modern Muslims reject the reports by
applying the methodology of hadith
scholars.
And so Muslims who reject the satanic
verses based on hadith methodology are
simply confused about the role of isnads
in the Sira magazi and tapsier
literature.
When we examine the satanic versus
reports based on the standards of the
sira magazi and tapsier scholars we find
that the reports are reliable.
Indeed, reports of the satanic verses
were accepted by the greatest of the
early Sierra scholars and Tapsier
scholars.
So, if we judge these reports based on
the types of literature they're actually
contained in, the reports turn out to be
as solid as just about anything from the
first century of Islam.
But just for fun, let's go ahead and
apply the standards of the hadith
scholars to the satanic verses because
sometimes people did include very
detailed isnads.
Here's an isnad that goes from Ibn
Mardawei back to Ibn Abbas, Muhammad's
cousin. Now, this is a complete chain.
Al- Siuti said that it was made up of
reliable transmitters.
So, what excuse do Muslim scholars come
up with to reject it?
Well, even though almost all of these
early guys are known to be reliable, we
don't know a lot about Muhammad Iban Ali
here. We have no reason to distrust him.
But if you're looking for any excuse
whatsoever to reject the chain, we don't
know much about him. Let's look at
another.
What's wrong with this is
it goes back to Abbas and everyone in
the chain is reliable. So why don't
Muslims accept it?
Well, one of the scribes who passed on
the report wrote a note saying that he
didn't trust it. He didn't trust it for
theological reasons. He couldn't believe
that Muhammad had delivered the satanic
verses. So, a scribe wrote a note saying
he didn't trust the report. And Muslim
scholars say there it says right there
that someone didn't trust it. It must be
false despite the fact that the entire
chain is sound.
If you're looking for any reason to
reject a version of the story, you can
apparently find one. But if you're
looking for the best explanation for the
evidence we have, it really, really
looks like at least the core of the
story is authentic.
As I said, hadith scholars were focused
on sayings and deeds of Muhammad that
established orthodox Islamic belief or
practice. And interestingly enough,
hadith scholars were fine with samagazi
and tapsier scholars using different
methodologies. The Hadith scholars would
say, "So and so is trusted in S, but we
don't trust him in hadith. So and so is
trusted in taps, but not in hadith."
They understood that they had different
purposes with different methodologies.
So why apply hadith methodology to
reports in different genres that used
different methodologies?
The Satanic Versus incident didn't
establish orthodox Islamic belief or
practice. Why apply hadith methodology?
During the second century of Islam,
Muslim scholars modified the doctrine of
ismat alambia, the protection of the
prophets.
The doctrine of Allah's protection of
the prophets originally meant that Allah
will protect a true prophet from
persisting in any major error. A prophet
might commit some major error, but Allah
would bring him out of it.
Well, that original doctrine didn't
conflict at all with the satanic versus
incident. On the contrary, the satanic
versus incident fit in perfectly with
this understanding of Allah's protection
of the prophets. Muhammad was deceived.
He committed a major error and Allah
corrected him. Since the story didn't
violate the doctrine, the hadith
scholars didn't interfere.
But the doctrine of Allah's protection
of the prophets changed over time.
Eventually during the second century,
the doctrine came to mean that Allah
would protect a true prophet from
committing any major error and that true
prophets are infallible when they
transmit revelation.
So when this modified doctrine of
Allah's protection of his prophets
became the orthodox position
in the second century, a conflict
started brewing. If Allah will protect a
true prophet from committing any major
error and if true prophets are
infallible when they transmit revelation
then reports of the satanic versus
incident are at odds with orthodox
Islam. In other words once the doctrine
changed sir magazi scholars and taps
scholars were interfering with and
contradicting orthodox Islamic belief
and practice. Hence the hadith scholars
began stepping in and over the centuries
the hadith scholars won in Islam.
But we have no obligation to obey the
changing standards and doctrines and
methodologies of later Muslim scholars.
So I don't see how we're under any
obligation to reject the satanic versus
incident based on these changing
standards and doctrines and
methodologies. So, we're free to go
where the earliest evidence points.
We can also encourage our Muslim friends
to carefully consider where their
beliefs really come from. Hadith
methodology doesn't come from Allah or
Muhammad. People made it up. Certain
doctrines like Allah's protection of the
prophets were modified by human beings
and used to rewrite history.
If, god forbid, I were a Muslim,
I would obviously have to believe that
Muhammad was a prophet.
But that wouldn't mean that I have to
treat later Muslim theologians and
historians as prophets who decide what I
have to believe. If I were a Muslim, I
think I would solve this problem by
rejecting the modified doctrine of
Allah's protection of the prophets and
return to the original doctrine which
allowed Muhammad to fall into major
error only to have Allah pull him out of
it.
[applause]